ladies and gentlemen Hasan Minhaj
thought there was avid event yo raise up
mods you got him close the door yeah
thank you for joining us there any
memories would stir up when I say that
phrase being a Muslim in America for me
it was September 12 I remember when it
happened my dad basically said everybody
had everybody down at the table and he
was like all right Hudson whatever you
do do not tell people in Muslim do not
talk about politics and I was like all
right cool this rubs off there phone
rings dad runs over to the phone we both
grab the phone at the same time and we
hear this voice on the line and it was
like hey camel jockey where's the Salma
my definitely why is it kind of can kill
you but Lane that's where you live right
click we sit down I hear sing outside so
me and Dad we run outside and all the
windows on the Camry are smashed Toyota
Camry carved toys for immigrants I look
in the middle discrete my dad is
sweeping glass out of the road like he
works at like a hate crime barber shop
he's like oh man like we got customers
like the neighbors will see you like I'm
gonna clear this out I'm livid I'm like
man these kids they're pranking us they
know where we live my dad's just
barefoot like super calm brown mr.
Miyagi and I thought what's wrong and he
goes uh this is the price we pay for
being here
so we lucked out and that's when I
realized my dad's from that generation
like a lot of immigrants who first come
to America where they feel like you got
to pay this thing like the American
Dream tax you come here you know dorsum
racism and if it doesn't cost your life
well hey you left out pay that tax
there's some days where I'm like he's
right you know put your head down go be
a doctor get a house in the burbs laughs
later and then I'm like wait it maybe
it's our job our generation to push the
needle forward little by little and make
it better for all of us so I say this a
lot man a lot of times a lot of
immigrant communities are Republican in
the sheets and Democrat in the streets
and then there's a lot of all right guys
that are there Republicans in the sheets
and they live in the sheets and they
wear sheet
in the Ku Klux Klan okay ladies
gentlemen huffing the nog
[Applause]